you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a California roll
and it was probably invented in Japan
wrong-o California nope it was invented
in Canada this is chef Tojo right
hi mrs. chef for Joe he held to make
sushi one of the most popular foods in
the US and Canada but to understand this
we have to take a look back it was 1971
and sushi wasn't popular when it came to
Japanese food people only liked a couple
things just people eat eat tempura and
also teriyaki turns out North Americans
they did not like seaweed no no no way
look terrible they said some people yeah
do you know so Tojo did something crazy
he wrapped the rice on the outside of
the ceiling to hide it in Japan people
they passing me well this is a long idea
wrong idea but people like it and chef
Tojo he did not stop there okay
everybody eat cucumber avocado and
cooked crab just a change this
preparation just low so he rolled these
preferred ingredients into one beautiful
amazing cuisine changing roll I didn't
call to California Lord we called inside
uncle where it is it got the name
California roll because it was so
popular with people who came to his
restaurant from LA and the roll made
people think differently about sushi it
was some sort of gateway roll people
starting with California law oh this is
very good then smoked salmon and tuna
step by step they loved it
chef Tojo's beginner roll was such a
success Japan's Ministry of Agriculture
Forestry and Fisheries appointed him as
the nation's goodwill ambassador for
Japanese cuisine and now sushi is
everywhere stickers on your notebook USB
drives play-doh molds wouldn't
twin sets everywhere maybe not all
thanks to chef Tojo but definitely
partly so disfigures what color should
be another she vows she no due to though
you heard me you ride a toccata oh yes
what the pseudonym Ella double out this
session on my tamil america days docket
okana antigua cyrano de la mejor modo
osaka na ban-seok otto so possible kabir
mattina so passive otto muy mas o Susilo
upon nidito Heian era todo o te gusta
tony accardo and se da le pont Aquino so
Shiva high on La Nina Dimas
today Muhammad right there sorry no
veneer natal no settler more unity the
headmaster da Cunha's she know you are
all knotty knotty must know they be
recorded forget da cunha oh poor handy
how to post a set up photons of good
monogamous forever sugar cane no cure in
anonymous Oh miss Ava you only have to
name my tend optical to kill Nina
so you're planning muscle what does she
did do Hadid I met another master super
commando Sally are on the schedule go to
the car Sarah bloom in Doc's iPhoto its
Lucas keys co-op Atari was so nervous
she got nomological I cannot show him
tada Tahari ánotá Mathematica cardinal
de makishima tiny cocoon of gelatinous
kkona kkona Nicodemus potestas discard
good ni cannot see they also she nodded
Oh
minna-san they deduct I thought oh my
god must
[Music]
it makes perfect sense for us to be
eating invasive species because invasive
species are an endless resource for food
my name is Bonnie I'm the chef that Mia
is sushi in New Haven 33 years ago my
mother started me as reimagining sushi
is something that is restorative of the
environment this is part of the regimen
that happens every day in the morning
the foraging one of the things that
we're really focused on is invasive
species what if we start focusing on
ingredients that nobody else wants to
eat that are abundant and even
destructive in the environment and by
pulling them out of the environment will
help rebalance that
habitat this is wild lettuce and we're
gonna serve them with bug holes in them
it's like Swiss cheese that means that
they're they're healthy to eat and that
their pesticide herbicide free here's a
big one really can't has it they have to
be fully committed to pitching see if I
am it got shot they're a lot stronger
than you think he's really pushing off
my hand yeah we're set to go it's rock n
roll
[Music]
great these snails from Europe they're
called European snails came over stuck
on ships I feel like you're like a big
kid just crawling around looking under
rocks when I'm collecting it's always
incredibly exciting it's very thrilling
for me well alright but when I'm trying
to figure out new ways of working with
an ingredient that I've never worked
with before or an ingredient that
actually grosses me out
I like the fact that I'm forcing myself
to confront my own prejudices today we
went foraging for dandelion amaranth
wild lettuce mugwort butterbur
grasshopper invasive European snails a
whole bunch of Asian shore crabs and
Waka Missy you eat in Brussels area
seaweed are you gonna be mad if we show
the whole world that you can make
gourmet sushi just using stuff in your
backyard that's what we want the whole
world to do or consider doing or think
about doing and not only that this isn't
an original idea people have been doing
this for tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of years way before before me
is and it's delicious and it's
absolutely delicious and nutritious and
great for the environment
[Music]
salmon sushi is in Japanese it's
Norwegian huh okay here's the story
until about 1995 raw salmon was not
consumed in Japan and this was for one
big reason Pacific salmon has parasites
oh so no salmon sushi sashimi no spicy
salmon nothing what
but obviously that all changed thanks in
part to this guy Norway had a problem
they had a lot of salmon and too small a
market looking east they set their
sights on Japan a country that loves raw
fish so much it's willing to pay five
times the price for sushi grade so Noor
we formed a committee and hired bjorn
from 1986 to 1991 I worked for okay
their job was to convince Japanese
consumers that Atlantic salmon was safe
to consume raw and this was hard just
take for example pork if some guy from
Norway came here and said here
er pork meat raw it's safe it's really
yummy we'd be like man you're crazy it
was basically American perception so we
had to change the whole country Buuren
and his team got to work they made the
first ever salmon rolls and serve them
to businessmen in Japan which they
didn't like for a long time it took
actually 10 years ok I get the proper
breakthrough in the knowledge so there
it is salmon sushi didn't exist before
1995 Bjorn on behalf of the world we
thank you
[Music]
this is some big sushi and if you're
hungry enough to eat this
there's a man you should meet another
young devil Ramos the only Jamal no she
just prepares oh and he makes the
smallest sushi too
[Music]
welcome to angio city in Japan home to a
small establishment with not so small
dishes hero mu has been making sushi
here for 44 years
[Music]
oh yeah you know come on I figure I know
like honestly she do I do something one
day a drunk customer challenged hero mu
to make the biggest sushi roll he could
so he whipped out the seaweed and
delivered
I didn't
[Music]
hero mu makes several infamous giant
sushi dishes who you know and my way I
thought wow oh yes Angie hooray Dom
immersive big sushi means big money he
Roma's generous roll cost 146 US dollars
Lala dr. McNamara that guy got you this
new guy he must get a new reel or June
animal we cannot solve any mistake you
gotta move natal you know why you put or
not have a mistake Nick my goodness and
what about the surprise eel that is how
a guy like you right
sorry guy insecure so it's gonna go
cavity mizuno-san Ebola but if for eels
sounds like a bit much here on also has
a plan could dainty R eaters and needs
as you are yes and a very you do believe
that you look desert
I lost Anna sees an opponent aside hold
on
[Music]
Hiromi serves his many sushi in a
matchbox
I saw me boku so look at that not only
us
Ichigo me destiny okay sometimes they
tell about whatever I never won this one
different UI that are granted over there
cuz I'm all month or that for the Cucuy
she's not there puttin up T
come on Teague hands at all
[Music]